[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the real reason that neville
longbottom was so bad at magic because
let's face it when you think neville
longbottom you do not think great and
powerful wizard but have you ever
considered why that may be have you ever
thought that neville's poor magical
performance may not have been his fault
at all okay so what exactly are we
talking about here well as some of you
harry potter super fans out there may
know there's a popular theory that
suggests the real reason neville was bad
at magic was because of his wand yes
that's right nothing to do with
neville's skill or ability to learn but
his wand you might be wondering how this
could be possible after all as diagon
alley's famous wand maker olivander
explains the wonder chooses the wizard
that much has always been clear to those
of us who have studied one law ah yes
the wand chooses the wizard not the
other way around which brings us to an
important point like most magical things
in the wizarding world a wand isn't any
old object devoid of for lack of a
better word life in fact they're
quasi-sentient unlike muggle school
supplies it's not just something that a
witch or wizard could quickly pick up
from a shop on their way home one day in
fact according to one law each one is
thought to have its own personality of
sorts that is to say just like people no
two ones are alike and even if multiple
ones are made of the same materials they
will be fundamentally impacted by
whoever they choose as their master i'm
sure how they perform can be best
predicted by wood type core material and
owner but sometimes even then a wand
could surprise you all right so back to
neville and his wand the big question
here is how could a wand that chose
neville be the very reason he's unable
to wield it properly as it turns out
neville's wand isn't neville's at all it
actually originally belonged to his
father frank longbottom before he and
his wife alice were tortured to insanity
by death eaters when neville was a baby
a terrible thing but we won't get into
that here okay so neville inherited his
father's wand by way of his gran augusta
longbottom frank longbottom's mother
augusta was very proud of her son frank
as both he and alice had been powerful
auras but is to say protectors against
the dark arts so it's reasonable to
think that by giving her grandson
frank's wand she may have been trying to
transfer her son's exceptional wizarding
skills onto neville or perhaps as an
older more conservative witch augusta
didn't want to spring for a new wand
whatever the reason neville ended up
inheriting frank longbottom's wand
at this point with ollivander's emphasis
on how the wand chooses the wizard you
may be wondering if inheritance is an
acceptable way to acquire a wand well
technically yes it is in fact there are
three different ways according to the
laws of ones to which a wizard can take
possession of a wand they are a new one
that selects a witch or wizard a wizard
wins another wizard wand and a one
disinherited let's take a closer look at
all three shall we okay so the first way
to acquire a wand we've already covered
in this video that is which wizard
visits a wondermaker and the one chooses
its master it's important to note that
this is without a doubt the absolute
best way to come by a wand it's believed
by those who study one law that when a
wonder chooses a witch or wizard that
which or wizard will have the best
mastery of their wand and the magical
power they wield
however a wizard should technically be
able to channel his magic through any
wand which brings us to the following
two ways to become new owner of a wand
the second method is to win it this can
happen in any number of ways from
disarming another witch or wizard to
winning a jewel the allegiance of the
one will be affected by how serious the
confrontation between wizards is for
example a practice jewel as part of a
lesson at hogwarts would not affect a
one's loyalty to its owner what's more
taking possession of a wand in this
manner is not nearly as effective as
having a wand to choose its master
because ones that tend to remain quite
sentimental and almost always maintain
some form of allegiance to their
original owner which brings us to the
third and final way in which a wand and
wizard can end up together inheritance
this is of course how neville came to
possess his first wand while this method
of acquiring a wand can work as we've
discussed in great detail it's not
nearly as effective as having one to
choose a wizard and while familial ties
may help with the one's allegiance
inheriting a wand is thought to be only
slightly better than picking up a random
wand off the street so yeah it's not
ideal so if neville's wand never chose
him this could explain a lot about his
magical mishaps throughout his early
years at hogwarts what's more with frank
longbottom still alive while neville
used his wand it's even more likely that
the one remain loyal to frank rather
than neville add this to the fact that
one of neville's strongest subjects was
herbology the study of magical plants
which was relatively light on one work
and you can start to see that perhaps
neville wasn't entirely to blame for how
poorly he did in school with a different
wand he may have been good or even great
at magic much earlier on now you may be
saying to yourself well hold on sure
neville started out as a bit of a dud
but didn't he come into his own later in
the series i'm glad you asked during the
battle of the ministry of magic in the
fifth book slash film harry potter in
order of the phoenix a death eater broke
neville's wand and knows poor bloke just
couldn't catch a break could he so then
after this battle he of course needed a
new wand he went to olivanders to
purchase one and after all that time
neville finally came to own a wand that
chose him from the end of the order of
the phoenix onwards neville suddenly
wasn't such a laughable character
anymore in my opinion it's not
completely obvious right away there's
not much to be said about neville
longbottom's magical competency in harry
potter and the half blood prince but by
year 7 while harry hermione and ron are
away from hogwarts searching for
horcraxes in harry potter and the
deathly hallows neville's star begins to
rise in the absence of harry neville
assumes a leadership role with
dumbledore's army and he's instrumental
in defeating voldemort not only is he
the one to kill nagini voldemort's
seventh horcrux and pet maledictus a
cursed individual who eventually becomes
a beast he did so by pulling the sword
of gryffindor from the sorting hat this
is a feat in itself as the sword of
gryffindor only reveals itself within
the hat to a true gryffindor an event
that further aligns neville's quality as
a wizard with the likes of harry potter
because as you may recall the sword of
gryffindor also appeared for harry way
back in the chamber of secrets
sure you could argue that those things
could have happened even if neville's
ability to perform magic hadn't improved
he could have just been a great leader
for the d.a and technically he didn't
use this one to pull the sword of
gryffindor from the sorting hat or kill
nagini but i like to think the students
in dumbledore's army looked up to
neville for both leadership and magical
skills so there you have it the real
reason neville was bad at magic very
well could have been his inherited wand
and once he got himself a new one he
definitely seemed to become a more
powerful wizard wouldn't you agree
this of course brings us to the end of
this video if you enjoyed the content
i'd be grateful if you liked it and
subscribed to the channel as always
happy to hear your input on this and
other harry potter theories just leave
them in the comments below and please
feel free to share any topics you'd like
to see in upcoming videos you guys
always have great ideas want to know
more about our dear boy neville for more
videos like this one be sure to check
out quivral tried to kill neville in the
philosopher's stone and neville's
remembral what did he forget
until next time
remember i'm worth 12 of you malfoy
you